welcome to this video playing Em's
Cashel Cashel let's see what we got
pretty surprised that it seems that I
haven't played him before feels like I
should have played him before way weird
let's see what we got it seems like a
no-name maybe there's some someone named
and quite similar blah
how boring do you want to be the London
system okay
just taking ages playing those moves I
should be really quick nice game
yeah trying to get him in time pressure
early I read on the clock I'm playing
quickly now yeah the good old head shock
this is how I am play this quite often a
six to have be five if he goes a 5-1
that's interesting somewhat mysterious
remove would expect rookie one to happen
but you went to d1 this is my setup that
I am normally play maybe he can go d5
now and precisely this position
maybe d5 wasn't move yeah this I'm not
fearing that much unless before a five
no it's not reacting here in any way I
thought you would play before maybe if I
get with the night to see five I'm
certainly okay yeah okay well Bishop
over to d7 maybe or I can also go to a
six maybe centralize first and then
Bishop a six
okay might behave it's not really a move
that scares me much can always scope it
should be a six and just take it what I
really want to do is to get Bishop g7
Knight h5 f5 going maybe you can prepare
before somehow trying to play against
this b6 pawn now that's certainly
possible but one thing I have in my
favor here the time situation I'm
actually ahead of the clock let me
activate this Bishop maybe I can take
only three at some point after b4 takes
Queen takes for example this could be an
idea
yeah it seems that he is not afraid of
that I probably did probably justified
okay do I want to go for f5 I can also
start with 94 maybe then f5 not clear
not clear on an IG for my [ __ ]
hmm yeah so kind of loose he can get a
five as well just opening up the
queenside
takes rook cheeks I was thinking that I
have some direct ideas okay I push this
come on quickly it's looks useful anyway
f5 head on the clock hmm
and it's not really accelerating maybe
you can can you do something crazy I
mean I don't know f3 Knight back you
came and I have to take that don't want
to allow like taking on be sex I have to
take look chicks what am i playing then
just okay it just trading maybe Wow but
sticking it to extremes is really slow
it or not maybe shouldn't be bad really
he always made bad maybe in his bed
let's do this
look at a team I take and play Queen f5
it's not that great yeah I was thinking
that maybe like f3 Knight Becca Bishop
f5 could be could be a move but it
didn't happen
hmm not so easy look to a7 now maybe
maybe I should do this put the Queen to
b6
it's an active position okay
he just wants to trade okay if I trade
now how did the six pawn is of course
vulnerable but I don't see how he he was
added uses it at the moment
f3 I will always take on history
obviously okay interesting move okay
not not very enthusiastic about that but
I cannot allow him to take and I also
cannot take myself okay now here yeah to
protect these six very interesting I
have to go here
yeah he's regrouping as bishop yeah 2g1
funny very interesting nice tip later
and he has played that well probably
this is now better wired to this
position I probably cannot allow him to
take maybe I can but I'm not sure not
sure about it man 94 55 and so on
that's definitely definitely true
trying to trade this the good thing is
that for one time behind the head on the
clock iam a very ugly position grab half
and take on d6 yeah I don't know I mean
it's not like I'm not sure how bad it is
I should take a draw here if I can
really justify to play on of course with
the time in mind that's it's pretty much
clear but okay I think this is something
that I can can continue to play there's
something
probably not much I can do yet at all
check check okay yeah fight for points
Oh once it should pay off that I was
quick here yeah I mean this was really
it was very very slow all the time and
it's not like I was totally lost while
winning on time yeah I mean around here
I mean this must be good right leg
should be okay what what exactly went
wrong here made me check this went here
takes digs huh yeah maybe I really have
to take on e3m I didn't want to do that
g4 was was really good I didn't see that
at all check this wasn't really really I
have to take actually I should really
take yeah yeah this is this is still
okay this is a bad piece yeah I should
do that here yeah I'm starting to get
into trouble I think I'm not sure how
bad it is well the computer is on zero
0.7 0.8 so it is substantial yeah but I
don't know is it lost maybe it is lost
but it's it's pretty in pretty tough I
guess yeah I'm not sure I think it
should be a draw now is maybe not it
depends really a bit on the concrete
position if I get a knight to f6 for
example it definitely is a draw but I
don't know if I managed to do that
yeah yeah it's it's probably it's
probably a drop so it's not like I'm
declining a drawing a totally lost
position okay well thanks for watching